We've all been there, the unexpected hosting panic. Like when the watch party finally makes it out of the group chat, but you volunteered to host, and suddenly you need snacks, drinks, dips, cups, and all the other party essentials no one else planned for. With Instacart, you can get all those groceries delivered in as fast as 60 minutes. No extra errands for you. One quick order for everyone. That way, everything shows up right on time, making hosting easy and making it look like you had it planned all along. Download the Instacard app today and get no markups at select retailers. Fees and in-store offer exclusions apply. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
我们都经历过那种意料之外的招待恐慌。就像观影派对终于从群聊里变成了现实，而你自告奋勇当东道主，结果突然发现你需要零食、饮料、蘸酱、杯子以及所有其他别人都没准备的派对必备品。通过 Instacart，你最快可以在 60 分钟内买齐所有这些杂货并送到家。你不需要再特地跑腿。一个人快速下单，搞定所有人。这样一来，所有东西都能准时送到，让招待客人变得轻松无比，还能让你看起来从头到尾都计划周全。今天就下载 Instacart App，在指定零售商处享受零加价。费用及店内优惠排除适用。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。
We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. We're just right on top of each other today. I know. That's what she said. That's what she said. I was just about to say that. Oh, boy. Oh, Lordy. What will this be? It's going to be so fun. If you guys just want just like about 50 minutes of joy and fun times, stick with us. We have a great episode today. I'm super excited about it.
我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的“办公室爱好者”播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节以及大量闺蜜故事，带你深入了解《办公室》的世界。我们是 Office Ladies 6.0。我们今天简直贴在一起了。我知道。这就是她说的。这就是她说的。我正要这么说呢。哦，天哪。哦，天呐。这会是什么样？这会非常有趣。如果你只需要大约 50 分钟的快乐和欢乐时光，那就和我们在一起吧。我们今天有一期很棒的节目。我对此超级兴奋。
Okay, first of all, I need to say this. Everyone listening, you know we record a few weeks in advance, right? Yeah. Yeah. Well, one reason I'm so excited about today is the week we're recording this is actually Jenna's birthday week. It's my birthday week. It's your birthday. So hello from early March. And by the time you hear this, it's going to be a few weeks after. But, you know, we have to celebrate the week of your birthday. Well, Angela, you do for sure because you love a birthday.
好吧，首先，我需要说明这一点。所有在听节目的听众，你们知道我们是提前几周录音的，对吧？是的。没错。好吧，我今天这么兴奋的原因之一，就是我们录制这期节目的这周实际上是珍娜的生日周。是我的生日周。是你的生日。所以向三月初的听众问好。等你们听到这期节目时，已经是几周后了。但是，你知道，我们必须庆祝你的生日周。好吧，安吉拉，你肯定会这么做，因为你热爱生日。
And I love this about you. You told me you wanted to do like a fun birthday episode today. I love it. I came in and there's a plant and a balloon from Sam and a book. And Angela, there's a gift bag here. and some homemade granola from Josh and a cake. And a cake. And some surprises you don't even know about.
我太喜欢你这一点了。你告诉我你想在今天办一期有趣的生日节目。我太喜欢了。我进来时，发现山姆送来了一盆植物、一个气球和一本书。安吉拉，这里还有一个礼品袋。还有乔希做的自制格兰诺拉麦片和一个蛋糕。和一个蛋糕。还有一些你甚至都不知道的惊喜。
What? Uh-huh. Oh, my goodness. That are going to be sprinkled through. You guys, I love a birthday. When we started our company, I said, everyone gets a dessert on your birthday and some kind of fun to do. These are our rules.
什么？嗯哼。哦，天哪。这些惊喜会穿插在节目中。你们这些家伙，我太爱生日了。当我们创立公司时我说过，每个人生日时都要得到一份甜点和某种好玩的活动。这就是我们的规矩。
We go to the bathroom when we need to go and we have a fun birthday. I love that when, you know, companies, when they're forming, they do encourage you to put together a mission statement, sort of a vision of your company. Yeah. And I love that when we did that, that two of our things were about going to the bathroom and celebrating birthdays. Yes. And I said we'll always have snacks. I think it really captures the two of us.
我们想上厕所的时候就去上厕所，我们要过一个快乐的生日。我喜欢这种说法，你知道的，公司在创立之初，确实会鼓励你制定一份使命宣言，也就是你公司的愿景。对。我喜欢我们当时这样做的时候，我们的两项目标竟然是关于上厕所和庆祝生日。是的。我说过我们随时都会有零食。我觉得这真的抓住了我们两个人的特质。
I said drawstring pants. This is like truly like lawyers. We had to open an LLC and all those things. Right, right. What's your mission statement for your company? This is what we provided. They're like, but like, what about like the business? Yeah, do you need insurance?
我说过要穿抽绳裤。这简直就像律师一样。我们不得不注册一家有限责任公司以及所有这些事情。对，对。你们公司的使命宣言是什么？这就是我们提供的。他们觉得，但是，商业方面呢？对，你们需要保险吗？
No, no, no, we're going to celebrate birthdays. Yes. Okay. Well, in honor of your birthday week, let's get to this episode that is called Jenna's birthday and call sheet questions. Woohoo. But you told me something I find intriguing and I can't wait to hear about it. You said that you have a birthday theme for yourself.
不，不，不，我们要庆祝生日。是的。好吧，为了庆祝你的生日周，让我们进入这期名为“珍娜的生日与通告单问题”的节目吧。呜呼。但你告诉我了一件让我觉得很着迷的事，我迫不及待地想听听。你说你给自己定了一个生日主题。
You told me this the other day. We were talking on the phone. And here's the thing I know about you. You love a theme. I love to name things. I don't know if I got this from Kendra or what, but naming things. It points me in a direction. But I have a theme for my 52nd year, and here's what it is. Books and Fabulous Women. This year, I want to read books and be around fabulous women. And I will tell you, it is already
你前几天跟我说过这个。我们在电话里聊天。关于你，我了解的是：你非常喜欢主题。我喜欢给事情命名。我不知道我是从肯德拉那里还是从哪里学来的，但给事情命名会给我指明一个方向。对于我的 52 岁，我有一个主题，内容是这样的：书籍与杰出的女性。今年，我想读书，并和杰出的女性在一起。而且我可以告诉你，这已经
happening. For my actual birthday, I'm having a little tea party with some book-loving women. and Angela, you're going to be there. I know. I'm very excited. I got a flowery dress. Oh. I just thought that's what you wear to a tea party. I'm literally throwing myself my own Finer Things Club for my birthday.
正在发生了。为了我的生日，我要和一些爱书的女性举行一个小茶会。安吉拉，你也会去。我知道。我很兴奋。我买了一条花裙子。哦。我只是觉得去茶会就该穿成这样。我简直是在为自己的生日举办我自己的“美好事物俱乐部”。
But I will also say this has already been one of my most memorable birthday weeks because it started with getting to present at the actor awards. I mean. Craziness. And talk about being on theme, getting to be with fabulous women. first off, just being with you and Ellie and Mindy, but also, lady, we got to meet so many women that I admire when we were at the awards. But I feel like I'm getting ahead of myself. Should we talk about how that all came about? Because it was crazy. It was a whirlwind for y'all listening. Tuesday morning, the week of the awards, I got a text at 8.15 in the morning.
但我也要说，这已经成为我最难忘的生日周之一，因为它是从去演员工会奖颁奖典礼担任颁奖嘉宾开始的。我是说。太疯狂了。说到切合主题，能和杰出的女性在一起。首先，能和你、埃莉和明迪在一起，不仅如此，女士们，我们在颁奖典礼上遇到了那么多我钦佩的女性。但我觉得我有点扯远了。我们该聊聊这一切是怎么发生的吗？因为太疯狂了。对你们听众来说，这简直是一场旋风。颁奖典礼那周的周二早上，我在早上 8 点 15 分收到了一条短信。
I'm like in my bathroom. I do like my little rose spray on my face in the morning and my eyedrops. what's happening, right? And my phone pings, and it's Mindy, and we're in a group text, and she's like, hey, ladies, I heard we might be presenting the award for Best Comedy Ensemble at the Actors Award this Sunday. Yeah. Excuse me what? What? What? Huh? Yeah. And by 9 a.m., it was locked. We were presenting. They had reached out to all the ladies of the office, the main cast. Kate Flannery was touring with Jane Lynch, so she was unable to go. Yeah. Phyllis was in St. Louis, and we were was just like, ladies, thanks for thinking of me, but I cannot get this together in time. Phyllis, I hear you, we were here in town and barely pulled it off.
我当时在浴室。我早上习惯在脸喷一点玫瑰喷雾，再滴眼药水。发生什么事了，对吧？然后我的手机响了，是明迪发来的，我们在一个群聊里，她说，嘿，女士们，我听说我们这周日可能会在演员工会奖上颁发最佳喜剧群戏奖。等等，什么？什么？什么？啊？是的。到早上 9 点，这事就敲定了。我们要去颁奖。他们联系了《办公室》所有的女性主演。凯特·弗兰纳里当时正和简·林奇一起巡演，所以她去不了。对。菲利斯在圣路易斯，而我们则是那种：女士们，谢谢你们想到我，但我实在没法及时把这事凑齐。菲利斯，我懂你，我们当时就在城里，也几乎是勉强搞定。
So it ended up being me and you and Ellie and Mindy and this scramble that started. We had five days to be a word show ready. It's so crazy to me that we were just talking to Chelsea Fry about this, about how, you know, when this whole thing started in our lives, we'd get invited to things. We'd be like, how do you get an outfit? How do you pull it off? Lady, 20 years later, I am no better at it. We were just still as, like, perplexed.
所以最后就成了我和你、埃莉还有明迪，然后就开启了一场手忙脚乱的筹备。我们只有五天时间准备好出席颁奖典礼。我觉得太疯狂了，我们刚才还在和切尔西·弗莱聊这件事，聊到当年我们生活中刚开始经历这一切时，我们会受到各种活动的邀请。我们会想：你怎么搞到一套礼服？你怎么驾驭它？女士，20 年过去了，我在这方面一点也没有进步。我们依然同样感到困惑。
We don't go to fancy shit anymore. No, we don't. We have been invited to things, you know, when we're like, eh. But, like, an award show. Presenting? Presenting with Mindy and Ellie. That's 100% a yes. But we had nothing.
我们再也不会去参加那种高级的破派对啦。不，我们不会。我们以前受邀参加过各种活动，你知道的，当时我们会想：呃。但是，像颁奖典礼这样的大场面呢？担任颁奖嘉宾？和明迪、埃莉一起颁奖？那百分之百是“去”。但我们什么都没有。
We don't have people. We don't have, like, I didn't know where I was getting anything. I was completely unprepared for also the glow-up, like, This is the thing that cracks me up. We get this information on Tuesday, three days before the award show, as we're scrambling to get outfits, Jenna sends me a picture and goes, I got those crest white strips. I was like, surely just two days of a 14-day crest white strip pack will totally transform my smile. I know.
我们没有团队。我们没有……比如，我根本不知道我要去哪里弄行头。对于随之而来的“颜值大升级”，我也完全没有做好准备。这是最让我忍俊不禁的地方。我们在周二，也就是颁奖典礼前三天得到了这个消息，当我们手忙脚乱地准备礼服时，珍娜发给我一张照片说：“我买了那些佳洁士美白牙贴。”我当时想，仅仅用 14 片装的佳洁士美白牙贴两天，肯定能彻底改变我的笑容吧。我知道。
I was like, oh, good idea. But then, Angela, you were like, I have a weird tan line on my arms from tennis. You guys, I have a full t-shirt tan. I have like a scoop neck around my neck, and then I have short sleeves, like a full t-shirt tan. But you're like, I'm going to sit outside for 30 minutes. In a tank top. Yeah, and I'm thinking, lady, 30 minutes is not going to fix this problem. And I'm sure you were like, good luck with your crest white strips.
我当时觉得，哦，好主意。但接着，安吉拉，你说：“我胳膊上有个打网球留下的奇怪晒痕。”你们大家，我有一个完整的 T 恤晒痕。我的脖子周围有一个大圆领印记，然后有短袖的痕迹，就像一个完整的 T 恤晒痕。但你说：“我要去外面坐 30 分钟。”穿着背心。是的，当时我在想，女士，30 分钟可解决不了这个问题。而且我敢肯定你当时在想：“祝你的佳洁士美白牙贴好运吧。”
I know. Which, by the way, I just want to say, really work if you do them for the 14 days. Like, they do work. You just need the whole thing. I don't want to disparage. I actually love them. I do too. I thought your teeth looked fine. Thank you. I don't know how we did it, but we pulled it all together. It definitely took a lot of effort on multiple people's parts, and I think we should thank a few people. We should because in addition
我知道。顺便说一句，我只想说，如果你真的坚持用满 14 天，它们真的很管用。真的有用。你只是需要用完整套。我可不想贬低它们。其实我很喜欢它们。我也是。我觉得你的牙齿看起来挺好的。谢谢。我不知道我们是怎么做到的，但我们真的把一切都搞定了。这绝对需要好几个人付出大量努力，我觉得我们应该感谢几个人。我们确实应该感谢，因为除了
to pulling it off, we had this hilarious text thread, Yumi, Ellie, and Mindy, like the night before we started sending each other pictures of what we were wearing, and we were weirdly magically coordinated. It was so cool. It was crazy. Also, like black and plum was where we landed. I tried on three dresses. Only one really fit me. So that's the one I went with. You guys all saw it. That's what Ellie said too. Yeah. And I loved it. Yeah. Loved it. I loved it. Your jumpsuit was so cool. Well, let me tell you what I did, lady. I reached out to my friend Lindsay Price, who I did splitting up together with. I have reached out to her before. She has dressed me. before from her own closet. She is my personal stylist. This is who I go to. It is such a cute thing about
顺利完成任务，我们前一晚还有了一个超级搞笑的群聊，我和你、埃莉还有明迪，大家开始互相发送我们准备穿的衣服的照片，结果我们诡异地、神奇地搭配到了一起。太酷了。太疯狂了。而且，我们最后选定的基调是黑色和李子色。我试了三条裙子。只有一条真的适合我。所以我穿的就是那条。你们大家都看到了。埃莉也是这么说的。对。我很喜欢。是的。非常喜欢。我很喜欢。你的连衣裤太酷了。好吧，让我告诉你我做了什么，女士。我联系了我的好友林赛·普赖斯，我们一起合作过《分道扬镳》。我以前联系过她。她以前用她自己衣橱里的衣服给我搭配过。她是我的私人造型师。这就是我要求助的人。
y'all's friendship because she's so fashionable. And every friend group needs one gal that knows fashion. This is your person. She's the Carrie Bradshaw of my friend group. She has the amazing closet of clothes. And I wrote to her because I knew she had this suit that I had worn when we did our book tour. I know. And I thought, can I? I borrow the suit. I know it fits. It's fabulous. She was like, I'll send the suit, but I have another idea. And she sent me this sequined jumpsuit. And she said, this is what I think you should wear. It was so cool. It was like beaded. It was strapless. It had this velvet like sash. It was very chic. I loved it. She added the sash. She did. Yeah. She was like sending you this sash because I think
你们俩的友谊太美好了，因为她超级有时尚感。每个朋友圈都需要一个懂时尚的姑娘。这就是你的专属人选。她就是我朋友圈里的凯莉·布拉德肖。她有着令人惊叹的衣橱。我写信给她，因为我知道她有这套西装，我在我们做图书巡回宣传时穿过。我知道。我在想，我能借这套西装吗？我知道它合身。它太棒了。她说：“我可以把西装寄给你，但我还有另一个主意。”她寄给我这条亮片连衣裤。她说：“我觉得你应该穿这个。”太酷了。上面有珠饰。是无肩带的。还配有一条天鹅绒的饰带。非常时髦。我很喜欢。她加上了饰带。是的。她当时说要寄给你这条饰带，因为我觉得
it'll elevate the outfit. She thought of that. The sash made it. I love the sash. I would have never I never thought of this, Ash. Same. I know. But then one problem, I couldn't sit in it. I couldn't sit down, really. I had to sit at an angle. It was an interesting car ride to the event.
它能提升整个造型的档次。这是她想到的。这条饰带简直是点睛之笔。我太喜欢这条饰带了。我绝对不会——我绝不会想到加一条饰带。我也是。我知道。但随之而来有一个问题，我穿着它根本坐不下来。我真的坐不下来。我必须侧着身子坐。去活动现场的车程可以说是相当有趣。
You had to lean back. Yes. And so after we presented, I changed into the suit. I did a wardrobe change. I've never done that before. You felt very badass. I did. I was like, where's Jenna?
你得往后靠。是的。所以在我们颁奖之后，我换上了那套西装。我换了一身行头。我以前从没这么做过。你觉得自己帅呆了。我是的。当时我在想，珍娜去哪儿了？
Ellie's like, she's in that tent. Like, they had a little area. Backstage. Where you could change. Yes. Yeah. My dress, I want to shout out my friend Kimmy, who's a stylist, and she's such a busy gal. She does so many high-end things.
埃莉说，她在那个帐篷里。就像他们有一个小区域。后台。你可以换衣服的地方。是的。是的。至于我的裙子，我要感谢我的朋友基米，她是一名造型师，她是个大忙人。她处理很多高端的事情。
And I just reached out to her, and I told her, like, on Tuesday at 9.30 a.m. Kimmy, I'm going to be presenting. She's like, oh, my God. And she brought over three dresses for me. And the one I wore was a loner. I borrowed it just for that night, which is also, like, stressful a little bit, because I'm like, can't get anything on this. You know.
我联系了她，在周二早上 9 点半告诉她：基米，我要去当颁奖嘉宾。她说：哦，天哪。她给我拿来了三条裙子。我穿的那条是借来的。我只借了那一晚，这也是，稍微有点压力，因为我在想：可千万别弄脏了。你知道的。
This is going back to someone. It's got to look good. Yeah. But thank you to the ladies that came together. I thought we all looked fantastic. Gosh, I felt really like glamorous, you know? I did too. It was fun.
这还是要还给别人的。必须得保持完美。是的。但非常感谢齐心协力的各位女士。我觉得我们当时看起来都棒极了。天哪，我真的觉得自己好有星光熠熠的感觉，你知道吗？我也是。太有趣了。
And the whole night felt special. From the minute we got there, we skipped the red carpet guys. We skipped it. Me and Jenna and Ellie were like not doing it. It gives me anxiety. We got to go into the artist entrance. Yes. But that was really cool.
而且整个夜晚都感觉很特别。从我们到达的那一刻起，我们直接跳过了红毯，伙计们。我们跳过了。我和珍娜还有埃莉都决定不走红毯。那让我觉得焦虑。我们可以从艺术家入口进去。是的。但这真的很酷。
It was cool. And then the minute you go backstage, there's the green room. This was like the glitziest green room. Hanging out with the other presenters, I felt like I was in the cool club. I'm never normally a part of. The first people that I saw when I walked in the green room was the entire cast of one battle. Minus Leo. Minus Leo. Of one battle after another. He's filming in Rome or something. I looked it up here. I was like, why isn't he? He didn't say he wouldn't be there. But I got to meet Tiana Taylor. Yes. We walked right. pastor, she looked amazing. Also, she is so warm and kind and lovely and brought her daughter.
太酷了。然后一走进后台，就是休息室。这简直是最金碧辉煌的休息室了。跟其他颁奖嘉宾一起闲逛，让我觉得自己加入了平时根本进不去的酷炫俱乐部。我走进休息室时看到的第一个人是《某种战斗》的全体演员。除了利奥。除了利奥。来自《接连不断的战斗》。他在罗马还是什么地方拍戏。我在那查了一下。当时我在想，他怎么没来？他没说他不来。但我见到了蒂亚娜·泰勒。是的。我们从她身边走过，她看起来状态好极了。而且她非常热情、善良、可爱，还带了她的女儿。
And I had sort of a list in my head of people that I hoped I could say to them, I loved your work this year. And she was one of them. And I did get to say that. And that was really cool. Yeah. She was lovely, just inside and out. But we also got to meet Odessa Desion from Marty Supreme. She was another one on my list. And do you know what I said to her, by the way? What? Because I've worked with her mom, Pamela Adlon, was her mom. And so I was like, oh my gosh, we tell your mom I said hi. And then I was like, what am I saying? I just turned into like that, like, dorky aunt. So she was on my list as well. And another person on my list was Wunmi Mosaku from Sinners. She was lovely. And seven months pregnant.
我脑子里其实列了一个名单，上面都是我希望有机会能对他们说“我今年很喜欢你的作品”的人。她就是其中之一。我真的对她说了。这真的很酷。是的。她整个人里里外外都太可爱了。但我们还遇到了来自《至尊马蒂》的奥德萨·阿德隆。她也是我名单上的另一个人。顺便说一句，你知道我对她说了什么吗？什么？因为我和她妈妈帕梅拉·阿德隆合作过，她妈妈是帕梅拉。所以我当时说，哦天哪，帮我向你妈妈问好。然后我就想，我在胡说八道什么呀？我简直变成了一个书呆子般的阿姨。所以她也在我的名单上。我名单上的另一个人是来自《罪人》的温米·莫萨库。她非常可爱。而且已经怀孕七个月了。
Seven months pregnant. She and I chatted about being really pregnant at an award show. I was super pregnant at the Screen Actors Guild Awards. That's what they were called back when we were nominated as a show. And she and I talked about just like navigating that night in like a big, long, flowy dress and just like, give me home. Well, she is amazing and sinners. If you guys haven't seen it. Yeah. She has this one scene in particular that just blew me away.
怀孕七个月。她和我聊了在颁奖典礼上挺着大肚子的感受。我在美国演员工会奖上时也是超级大肚。当我们剧组获得提名时，颁奖典礼以前就叫这个名字。她和我聊了穿着又大、又长、飘逸的裙子如何应付那一晚，以及只想回家躺着的感觉。不过她在《罪人》里的表现太棒了。如果你们还没看的话。是的。她有一场戏特别震撼到我。
Talk about someone who can command a moment. Yes. Yeah. Yes. And lady, you chatted with Gwyneth Paltrow. I look over who's so tall. She's very tall. Well, next to me, too.
说到那种能掌控全场的演员。是的。是的。是的。而且女士，你和格温妮丝·帕特罗聊天了。我转头一看，她好高啊。她非常高。好吧，站在我旁边也是。
Big difference. Hey. Well, I mean, it was a striking difference. She's really so tall. And I had on three-inch heels, so... I'm right in the middle of you guys. Well, here's the thing. When we walked out on stage,
差距很大。嘿。好吧，我的意思是，这差距太明显了。她真的是太高了。而且我当时还穿着三英寸的高跟鞋，所以……我就站在你们俩中间。好吧，事情是这样的。当我们走上舞台时，
they had an order. I walked out first, and then Jenna and then Ellie and then Mindy, right? We walked out in this order. So I'm the first one walking out there by myself, and I was like, ah, the person I lock eyes with, I'm standing right in front of is Gwyneth Paltrow.
他们是按顺序来的。我第一个走出去，然后是珍娜、埃莉，最后是明迪，对吧？我们是按这个顺序走出去的。所以我是第一个独自走上台的人，当时我在想，啊，我目光锁定的人，正站在我面前的那个人是格温妮丝·帕特罗。
And I look right at her and I make this kind of smile like, hey, and she smiled right back. And then I sort of left my body because then I looked at the whole room and I was like, oh my gosh, what are we doing? And I got a little nervous for a second. But after the word show was over, we were walking like towards the exit together. And I turned to her and I said, Gwyneth, I'm Angela Kinsey. And she was like, hi. And I said, I just wanted to say thank you.
我直直地看着她，露出了一个类似于“嘿”的微笑，她也冲我微微一笑。然后我整个人差点灵魂出窍，因为接着我环顾了整个房间，心里想：哦天哪，我们在干什么？我紧张了一小会儿。但在颁奖典礼结束后，我们一起朝出口方向走去。我转过身对她说：“格温妮丝，我是安吉拉·金西。”她说：“嗨。”我说：“我只是想对你说谢谢。”
I locked eyes on you right as I walked on stage. and I was a little nervous and I kind of gave you this dorky smile and you smiled right back and just kind of settled my nerves. And she was like, oh my goodness, you guys were fantastic. And she was really nice. Well, you know who I locked eyes with as I walked out on stage right in front of me. Connor's story. I know.
我刚走上舞台时，目光就和你对上了，我当时有点紧张，冲你露出了一个书呆子般的傻笑，而你直接冲我笑了笑，这让我稍微平静了下来。她说：“哦天哪，你们刚才太棒了。”她人真的很好。好吧，你们知道当我走到舞台正前方时，我和谁目光对视了吗。康纳·斯托瑞。我知道。
Sitting right there next to Sarah Paulson. And I locked eyes with him and I went, ah. I was being a fan of his work. But then later, like you, crazy. This is a crazy moment for me. We ended up sharing a chair. You did because we, you know how, like in the commercial breaks, people get up and chat. Yeah. So we got up and we were chatting. And then when the show starts back, you quickly have to sit down wherever you are. It's like musical chairs. It is. And I sat in Sarah Polson's chair, Sarah, sorry, I took your chair and Sarah crouched
他就坐在莎拉·保罗森旁边。我和他目光交汇，然后我“啊”了一声。我当时完全是在崇拜他的作品。但后来，就像你一样，太疯狂了。这对当时的我是个疯狂的时刻。我们最后竟然共用了一把椅子。你确实坐了，因为我们，你知道的，就像在广告插播时，大家会站起来聊天。对。所以我们站起来聊天。然后当节目重新开始时，你必须快速坐在你所在的任何地方。就像抢椅子游戏一样。确实是。我坐在了莎拉·保罗森的椅子上，莎拉，对不起，我坐了你的椅子，于是莎拉蹲
on the ground next to me. I was like, Sarah, I'm so sorry. And you quickly sat down and you and Connor sat. set. We sat on the same chair. Same chair. Oh, but you guys, it was just, it was amazing. I'm sorry if we're going on and on, but we haven't been to one of these in a real long time. And it was just so fun. I finally got to meet Quinta Brunson, which was another highlight. And we got to hang out with Paul Muskell and Jesse Buckley. Oh, my God. Backstage. Jesse Buckley offered to take our picture. I was like, what is happening? Yes, we were like, can we get a picture with you? And at the party afterwards, we saw Rose Byrne, who I love, and Catherine Hahn, who I've been friends with for so long. And Rea Seahorn was at our table with her son. Her son. Mm-hmm. She was wonderful. And Sterling K. Brown.
在我身边的地上。我说：“莎拉，真的很对不起。”然后你赶紧坐下，你和康纳坐在一起。我们坐了同一把椅子。同一把椅子。哦，不过伙计们，这真的是太棒了。抱歉，如果我们唠叨个没完，但我们已经很久没有参加过这种活动了。而且真的太好玩了。我终于见到了昆塔·布恩森，这也是另一个亮点。我们还在后台和保罗·麦斯卡以及杰西·巴克利一起闲逛。哦，天哪。杰西·巴克利主动提出帮我们拍照。我当时想：这到底是什么情况？是的，我们当时问：能和您合个影吗？在后来的派对上，我们看到了我非常喜欢的罗丝·伯恩，还有我认识很久的朋友凯瑟琳·哈恩。雷·西霍恩和她的儿子也坐在我们桌旁。她的儿子。嗯哼。她太棒了。还有斯特林·K·布朗。
Who called me Ange. I know. And I was like, Sterling, my family calls me Ange. How do you know people call me Ange? And he said, well, my sister's name Angela and I call her Ange. Well, there you go. And I was like, Sterling, you can call me Ange forever. We've dropped so many names.
他叫我安吉（Ange）。我知道。我当时说：“斯特林，我的家人都叫我安吉。你怎么知道别人叫我安吉？”他说：“哦，我妹妹叫安吉拉，我叫她安吉。”好吧，原来是这样。我说：“斯特林，你可以永远叫我安吉。”我们刚才抛出了太多大名鼎鼎的名字了。
We have. Sorry. But all of these people were wonderful. So if you want to know what they're like, the answer is wonderful. And maybe most wonderful of all, not that it's a contest, sweet darling Oliver Hudson with the crazy tattoo. We ran into him. He's so fun. And here's the thing about Oliver.
确实。抱歉。但所有这些人都是那么棒。所以如果你想知道他们是什么样的人，答案就是：太棒了。也许其中最棒的——虽然这不是一场比赛——是可爱迷人的奥利弗·哈德森，还带着那个疯狂的纹身。我们碰到了他。他太有趣了。关于奥利弗，有这么一回事。
You know him way better than I do. Obviously, y'all did show together. But when you meet him, he's one of those people where you feel like you've known him your whole life. Yeah. He's so. No, he's just so easy to be around. And he told me, this is what's crazy. Guess what? I said that this night was full of fabulous women. Guess what? Books made their way in
你比我了解他得多。显然，你们俩一起演过节目。但当你遇到他时，他就是那种让你觉得仿佛认识了一辈子的那种人。是的。他太……不，他就是那种让人相处起来非常轻松的人。他告诉我——这才是最疯狂的。你猜怎么着？我刚才说这个夜晚到处都是杰出的女性。你猜怎么着？书本也出现在这个夜晚了。
because Oliver Hudson is a voracious reader. Oh yeah. We actually got, I won't say reprimanded, is the right word, but there was a security man that said, you need to leave now. Because everyone had to exit into the party that you spill into this party next door. And you two were talking about the books you were reading, and you were so invested in this conversation, I was like, y'all need to walk. Talk. Yeah. And then the next day, just texting about books. So Oliver's going to be my book friend this year, I think. He also said he's going to come on the podcast. We think we need to play two truths and a lie with him. I think we do too. All right. Congratulations on your birthday theme of fabulous women and books. Yes. We have some fun surprises plan for you. I think we should take a quick break, have some birthday cake.
因为奥利弗·哈德森是一个狂热的读书爱好者。哦，是的。我们实际上被——我不会说“训斥”，用这个词不太准确，但当时有一个保安说：“你们现在得离开。”因为所有人都要走到隔壁那个派对的会场去。你们俩当时还在滔滔不绝地聊着各自正在读的书，你们对那个话题实在是太投入了，我当时就想：你们俩得边走边聊了。边走边聊。是的。然后第二天，大家还在发短信讨论书。所以奥利弗今年要成为我的书友了，我觉得。他还说他要来上这个播客。我觉得我们得跟他玩个“两真一假”的游戏。我觉得我们真的应该这么做。好了。祝贺你迎来了以“杰出的女性和书籍”为主题的生日。是的。我们为你计划了一些有趣的惊喜。我觉得我们应该休息一下，吃点生日蛋糕。
And when we come back, we're going to do the call sheet questions in honor of your birthday. Great. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships, and families, and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve. Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence.
等我们回来之后，我们要为了庆祝你的生日来玩通告单问题。太棒了。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，我们要花点时间来庆祝女性以及她们在工作、人际关系、家庭以及她们每天扮演的众多角色中所承担的一切。我们需要提醒自己，我们有多么重要，治疗为我们提供了一个空间，让我们能够以应有的方式照顾自己。治疗也可以是一个设定界限和建立自信的地方。
Just take care of your own well-being for a chance. BetterHelp makes therapy accessible and flexible. Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and it works, with an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, help.com slash office ladies. Have you ever felt like you are living just a B or B plus life? It's so dangerous to live that. More dangerous than a B minus or a C plus life? Because when you're living a B or B plus life, you don't change it. You think it's good enough.
至少试着去照顾一下你自己的身心健康。BetterHelp 让心理治疗变得触手可及且灵活多样。他们的治疗师在美国拥有完全执照，并遵循严格的行为准则。BetterHelp 拥有超过 3 万名治疗师，是全球最大的在线心理治疗平台，而且它切实有效，根据 170 多万条客户评价，实时咨询的平均评分为 4.9 分（满分 5 分）。你的情感健康至关重要。在心理治疗中寻找支持并卸下心理负担。注册并在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 享受 9 折优惠。网址是 betterhelp.com/officeladies。你是否曾经觉得自己过着只是 B 级或 B+ 级的生活？过这种生活太危险了。比过 B- 级或 C+ 级的生活更危险吗？因为当你过着 B 级或 B+ 级的生活时，你不会去改变它。你会觉得它已经够好了。
Is it? I'm Susie Welch. I host a podcast called Becoming You. People think, okay, an A plus life is not available to me, but there is a way. We are all in the process of becoming ourselves. Listen to becoming you wherever you get your podcasts. Right, we are back. And before we kick off the call sheet questions,
真的是这样吗？我是苏茜·韦尔奇。我主持一个名为《成为你自己》（Becoming You）的播客。人们会想，好吧，A+ 级的生活不适合我，但其实是有办法的。我们都在成为自己的过程中。无论你在哪里收听播客，都请收听《成为你自己》。好，我们回来了。在开始通告单问题之前，
I have two fun things we're going to do in honor of your birthday. Okay. The first thing is, I'm going to share with you some trivia from March of 1974. The year you were born, Ms. Fisher. The number one grossing movie, the month of March in 1974, was the Great Gatsby. starring Robert Redford and Mia Farrow. Oh, wow. You know I've never seen it.
我有两个有趣的环节要为了你的生日进行。好的。第一件事是，我要和你分享一些来自 1974 年 3 月的冷知识。费舍尔女士，那是你出生的年份。1974 年 3 月票房最高的电影是《了不起的盖茨比》。由罗伯特·雷德福和米亚·法罗主演。哦，哇。你知道我从来没看过。
Really? Yeah, I saw the Leo DiCaprio one. You should see the original since it was the big hit the month you were born. Done. I'm going to do it this weekend. The top television shows The Month You Were Born in 1974 were all in the family and Sanford and Son. Wow. Mm-hmm.
真的吗？对，我看过莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥演的那版。既然那是你出生那个月的超级热门电影，你应该看看原版。没问题。我这周末就去看。1974 年你出生那个月的热门电视节目是《一家子》和《桑福德和儿子》。哇。嗯哼。
Those are two really cool shows. The number one song The Month You Were Born was Seasons in the Sun by Terry Jacks. Well, the music was moody. The film was kind of romantic and over the top. And the television was very cutting edge. Yes. Hmm.
这是两个非常酷的节目。你出生那个月排名第一的歌是特里·杰克斯的《阳光下的季节》。好吧，音乐很有情绪感。电影有一种浪漫且夸张的风格。而电视剧非常前卫。是的。嗯。
I like it. I like the artistry of my birth year. You were meant to be an artist, is what it tells me. All right. And now are you ready for a little birthday surprise? We've had birthday trivia. Now it's birthday surprise. Okay.
我喜欢。我喜欢我出生年份的艺术气息。这告诉我，你注定要成为一名艺术家。好啦。现在你准备好迎接一个小小的生日惊喜了吗？我们刚才回顾了生日冷知识。现在是生日惊喜环节。好的。
I reached out to Matt and Sam, and I said, Jenna loves books. This is part of her birthday year theme. I want us each to read a little passage from a book that we love. That means something to us. I love this. And then, lady, you are going to be getting the books we talked about. This is so exciting.
我联系了马特和山姆，我说：珍娜喜欢书。这是她生日年主题的一部分。我想让我们每个人都从自己喜爱的一本书中朗读一小段文字。这对我们有意义的文字。我太喜欢这个了。然后，女士，你将会收到我们刚才聊过的这些书。太令人兴奋了。
Yes. All right, Sam, why don't you go first? Sure. Okay, so this is a poem, actually. It's only six paragraphs long, but I've heard the end of it my entire life. but I just recently heard the entire thing. It's by Dylan Thomas. It's called Do Not Go Gentle Into That Good Night.
是的。好的，山姆，你为什么先来？没问题。好的，这其实是一首诗。只有短短六段，但我一生都在听这首诗的结尾。不过我最近才听到完整版。这是迪兰·托马斯的诗。名字叫《不要温和地走进那个良夜》。
It says, Do not go gentle into that good night. Old age should burn and rave at close of day. Rage, rage against the dying of the light. The wise men at the end know dark is right, because their words had forked no lightning, they do not go gentle into that good night. Good men, the last wave by, crying how bright their failed deeds have danced in a green bay, rage against the dying of the light. Wild men who caught and sang in the sun in flight,
上面写着：“不要温和地走进那个良夜，老年应当在日幕时分燃烧、咆哮；怒斥，怒斥那光明的消逝。智慧的人临终时懂得黑暗是必然的，因为他们的话语没有迸发出闪电，他们不愿意温和地走进那个良夜。善良的人，当最后一波浪潮过去，哭喊着他们的伟大功绩曾在绿色的海湾里多么绚烂地舞蹈，怒斥那光明的消逝。狂暴的人抓住并歌唱过飞翔的太阳，
we learned too late they grieved on its way. Do not go gentle into that good night. Grave men near death who see with blinding light, blind eyes could blaze like meteors and gay. Rage against the dying of the light. And you, my father, there on the sad height, curse, bless me now with your fierce tears, I pray. Do not go gentle into that good night.
他们直到太迟才明白自己曾在路上悲伤。不要温和地走进那个良夜。严肃的人临近死亡时，用失明的双光看到，瞎了的眼睛可以像流星一样燃烧、欢快。怒斥那光明的消逝。还有你，我的父亲，在那悲伤的高处，我祈求你，用你凶猛的泪水诅咒我、祝福我吧。不要温和地走进那个良夜。
Rage against the dying of the light. So that was written by Dylan Thomas, and I want to say, 1940, but it reminded me of you. I am naturally very complacent. It's a Wisconsin upbringing. I'm very docile. It very easily will fall in line with things. But you strike me as somebody who knows exactly what they want at a light, is very particular and isn't afraid to change the things in their life to get what they want. I've always really admired that about you. I think in this 52 years you've been alive, I think you are successfully raging against the dying light. Sam, first of all, I love
怒斥那光明的消逝。”这首诗是迪兰·托马斯写的，我想说，大约在 1940 年，但这让我想到了你。我天生非常随遇而安。这是威斯康星州养育出来的性格。我很温顺。我非常容易顺应事情的发展。但你给我的印象是一个确切知道自己想要什么、行事非常果断、并且不害怕为了得到自己想要的东西而改变生活中事物的人。我一直非常佩服你这一点。我觉得在你活过的这 52 年里，你一直在成功地怒斥那消逝的光明。山姆，首先，我太
that you picked poetry because it is a sect of literature that I'm less familiar with. Yeah, me too. And I would love to know more. So I'm excited that poetry is coming my way. You're getting the book, The Poems of Dylan Thomas. And I love that poem. And everything you just said, that just means so much to me. Oh, great. Happy birthday. I love you. Thank you. I love you. That was so beautiful, Sam. Damn you. but Matt, you have a book. Now, this is a book Jenna already has. So Jenna, you're going to be getting two books. Okay.
高兴你选了一首诗，因为我对文学中的这个领域不太熟悉。是的，我也是。我很想了解更多。所以我很高兴诗歌向我走来。你要得到的那本书是《迪兰·托马斯诗集》。我很喜欢那首诗。你刚刚说的所有话，对我来说意义太重大了。太棒了。生日快乐。我爱你。谢谢。我也爱你。山姆，那太美了。该死的。不过马特，你也有书要送。现在，这本书珍娜已经有了。所以珍娜，你要收到两本书。好的。
Because this one, we believe you have. But Matt, I'll let you take it from there. Well, yeah, when I first came on the show, we were reading the same book, a marriage at sea. And I really thought that was so cool, you, me, and Barack Obama, because it was on his book list for the year. Oh.
因为这本书，我们觉得你已经有了。不过马特，我让你接着说。好的，是的，当我刚来这个节目的时候，我们俩正在读同一本书，叫《海上婚姻》。我真的觉得这太酷了，你、我和巴拉克·奥巴马，因为这本书上了他当年的书单。哦。
But I just thought that was awesome. And I was like, oh, cool, we have a shared love of this book. We're reading at the same time. So I picked a quote from that. And this is from A Marriage at Sea by Sophie Elmhurst, which was a great book about a couple surviving at sea together. And the quote is, I believe in all human beings, there is a desire to love and be loved to experience the full fierceness of human emotion and to make it a measure of the success of one's life. And I really love that to quote rent to measure your life and love. So, yeah, I hope it's a wonderful year for you with lots of love.
但我当时觉得这太棒了，我想：哦，太酷了，我们对这本书有着共同的热爱。我们在同时阅读。所以我从中挑选了一段引言。这段话出自索菲·埃尔姆赫斯特的《海上婚姻》，这是一本关于一对夫妻在海上共同求生的好书。引言是：“我相信，所有人类内心深处都有一种去爱与被爱的渴望，去体验人类情感的极致汹涌，并将其作为衡量一个人一生成功与否的标准。”我真的很喜欢这段引用，租借你的生活去衡量爱与生命。所以，是的，我希望这是充满爱意、美好的一年。
Thank you, Matt. And I love that you threw a little theater into there as well. I love it. Yeah, that's a beautiful passage and that book is really incredible. And now I know if I ever meet Barack Obama, I can bring up this book. You can talk books. Yeah. Thank you. Okay, Angela, your turn. Okay, my turn. So I brought a book in because, you know, I love show and tell. But this book is really special to me because it was one of my dad's favorite books. And when he passed away, my mom gave me a bunch of his favorite books. My dad was always reading a book. He had a lot of long hours that he traveled back and forth to the rig, and he would read when he traveled. So this is one of his favorite books, and there's a connection to my hometown as well. This is my dad's copy of Lonesome Dove by Larry McMurtry, and it won the Pulitzer.
谢谢你，马特。我也很高兴你还在里面加入了一点戏剧元素。我喜欢。是的，这是一段非常美丽的文字，那本书也真的不可思议。现在我知道了，如果我以后遇到巴拉克·奥巴马，我可以提起这本书。你们可以聊书。谢谢。好的，安吉拉，轮到你了。好的，轮到我了。我带了一本书来，因为，你知道的，我喜欢“展示与讲述”。但这本书对我很特别，因为这是我爸爸最喜欢的书之一。他去世后，我妈妈给了我一堆他最喜欢的书。我爸爸总是手不释卷。他以前经常要花很长时间开车往返于钻井平台，他在路上就会读书。所以这是他最喜欢的书之一，而且它和我的家乡也有渊源。这是我爸爸的藏书——拉里·麦克默特瑞的《没滋没味的小镇》（Lonesome Dove），它获得过普利策奖。
So this was really amazing for me to go back. Written in here, it says given to Billy Kinsey for his 50th birthday in Archer City, Texas on July 26, 1985. And I don't think you have this book. I don't. Okay. So it's this epic Western novel written by Larry McMurtry, who's from Archer City, from my hometown. And we all grew up knowing his family. My mom is very good friends with his sister. I went to school with his nephew. My dad went to school with Larry for a while. So this is very rooted in our hometown. But more than that, The book is just a really beautiful story about love and loss and friendship and the end of the Old West. It's got a huge large cast of characters.
所以对我来说，能重新翻阅这本书真的太神奇了。上面写着：送给比利·金西，作为他 50 岁生日礼物，1985 年 7 月 26 日于德克萨斯州阿彻城。我觉得你没有这本书。我没有。好的。所以这是一部宏大的西部小说，作者拉里·麦克默特瑞就来自阿彻城，我的家乡。我们从小就认识他的家人。我妈妈和他妹妹是很好的朋友。我和他侄子是一个学校的。我爸爸曾经和拉里上过一段时间同一所学校。所以这本书深深扎根于我们的家乡。但不仅如此，这本书本身就是一个非常美丽的关于爱、失去、友谊以及旧西部时代终结的故事。里面有大量庞大的角色阵容。
And it really centers around Augustus McCray and Woodrow Call, who are these Texas Rangers, and they're on this very dangerous cattle drive from Texas to Montana. But there's so much love and life that happens to them and the people around them along the way. And there was two things that I like. And I find that I like the things Augustus says. He's such a bigger than life personality. But one of the things he says in the book that I liked is, if you want one thing too much, it's likely to be a disappointment.
它的核心围绕着奥古斯都·麦克雷和伍德罗·考尔，他们是德克萨斯骑警，他们正在进行一次非常危险的从德克萨斯到蒙大拿的驱赶牛群之旅。但在他们以及周围人沿途的经历中，发生了太多的爱与生活。有两点是我很喜欢的。我发现我很喜欢奥古斯都说的话。他的个性太鲜明、太有活力了。他在书中说过的一句话我很喜欢：“如果你对某件事物的期望过高，那它很可能会带来失望。
The healthy way is to learn to like the everyday things like soft beds and buttermilk and feisty gentlemen. And then the other one, a lot of people, like when you look up like quotes that people love from this book, this is one that a lot of people say. but I loved the idea of just being comfortable with everyday things, and that is you to me. You really enjoy just your cup of coffee in the morning makes you so happy. It does. Sitting in your cozy nook and reading a book or going for a walk with Lee. These are the things that just fill your bucket, right?
健康的方式是学会喜欢日常生活中的小事，比如柔软的床、酪乳和脾气火爆的绅士。”还有另一句话，很多人——就像当你在网上搜索大家最喜欢这本书里的哪些名言时，很多人都会提到这句。但我很喜欢那种安于日常小事的心态，这简直就是你给我的感觉。你真的很享受早上的一杯咖啡，这就能让你非常开心。确实如此。坐在舒适的角落里读书，或者和李一起去散步。这些就是能让你感到充实的事情，对吧？
And afternoon with your kids, just hanging out in the backyard with your dog, Maggie, and just those little moments are you. And this one is one other quote. share, it ain't dying, I'm talking about, it's living. I doubt it matters where you die, but it matters where you live. And I see you embrace that all the time, especially the journey you've been on the last few years. You know, you want to make now matter. Oh, wow. Yeah. So you will be getting a copy of Lonesome Dove. I'm very excited, you know, I particularly love stories, like, on a prairie. I love prairie life stories. I didn't know that. Well, they have a very kind of survivalist
下午和你的孩子们在一起，在后院和你的狗玛吉一起闲逛，那些小小的时刻就是真正的你。我还想分享另一句话：我说的不是死亡，而是活着。我怀疑你在哪里死并不重要，重要的是你在哪里活。我看到你一直在践行这一点，尤其是你过去几年经历的这段旅程。你知道的，你想让当下变得有意义。哦，哇。是的。所以你会得到一本《没滋没味的小镇》。我非常兴奋，你知道的，我特别喜欢那种发生在草原上的故事。我喜欢草原生活的故事。我不知道这一点。好吧，它们有一种非常强烈的求生主义
aspect to them. Yes. Because like so much of the day is just about gathering food. Survival. Yes. You know, and cooking the food and trading the food. So I love prairie stories. So I think I will enjoy. This sounds like there's some ranching in there. I'm here for it. There's a lot of ranching. And there's a lot of just life and really interesting characters. If someone drinks coffee like out of a tin cup over a fire, I'm going to love it. You're in. And lady, my last gift for you is to just honor your heart for service. You volunteer.
色彩。是的。因为很大一部分时间，每一天都只是关于收集食物。生存。是的。你知道的，烹饪食物和交换食物。所以我很喜欢草原故事。所以我觉得我会喜欢。听起来里面有一些牧场生活。我非常期待。里面有很多牧场生活。还有许多生活琐事和非常有趣的角色。如果有人用锡杯在火堆旁喝咖啡，我肯定会爱死它。你绝对会喜欢的。女士，我送给你的最后一件礼物是为了致敬你热心公益的心。你经常去做志愿者。
You donate a lot of your time and resources to helping the unhoused people in your area. This is true. You never talk about it. You don't brag about it. but it is a wonderful thing that I know about you. So in honor of your birthday lady, I made a donation to the Library Foundation of Los Angeles. Thank you.
你捐出了大量的精力和资源来帮助你所在地区的无家可归者。这是真的。你从来不谈论这件事。你从不吹嘘。但这是我所了解的关于你的一件非常美好的事情。所以在你生日之际，女士，我向洛杉矶图书馆基金会进行了捐赠。谢谢。
You're welcome. I just thought, you know, I want to support this part of you that I love. And the Library Foundation of Los Angeles provides critical support to the Los Angeles Public Libraries. That results in free programs, resources, and services available to millions of adults, children, and youth. and by supporting the Library Foundation of Los Angeles,
不客气。我只是觉得，你知道的，我想支持你身上我最热爱的这个特质。洛杉矶图书馆基金会为洛杉矶公共图书馆提供关键支持。这使得数以百万计的成人、儿童和青少年能够获得免费的项目、资源和服务。通过支持洛杉矶图书馆基金会，
you help transform lives because your generosity is ensuring that the public library thrives for generations to come. Well, that means so much to me. Thank you, guys. Oh, my gosh. You know what has been so special about this is how very seen and known I feel right now. I'm so glad. I'm so glad.
你正在帮助改变人生，因为你的慷慨确保了公共图书馆在未来世世代代都能蓬勃发展。这对我意义重大。谢谢你们。哦，天哪。你知道这其中最特别的是什么吗，就是我现在觉得自己被深深地看见和了解了。我太高兴了。我太高兴了。
Thank you. I feel like as we age birthdays, they just mean different things, you know? And we're not in our, let's go out and party birthday phase. No. We're like, and let's just be around the people that we love and know us. Yeah. Oh, thank you. Thank you, guys.
谢谢。我觉得随着我们年龄的增长，生日意味着不同的东西，你知道吗？我们已经不在那种“出去疯狂派对”的生日阶段了。不。我们现在的状态是：让我们和那些爱我们、了解我们的人在一起。哦，谢谢。谢谢你们。
Happy birthday. Thank you. Happy birthday. All right. Now it's time for the call sheet questions with Jenna. You all listening know the call sheet questions. We've talked about the many times. They were the questions on the back of our call sheets while we were working on the set of the office.
生日快乐。谢谢。生日快乐。好了。现在是和珍娜一起进行通告单问题的环节。所有在听节目的听众都知道通告单问题。我们聊过很多次了。当我们在《办公室》片场工作时，这些问题就印在通告单的背面。
Kind of a fun way to get to know you. And we're going to ask them to Jenna today. Number one, what was your first entertainment job? Well, I think I've talked about both of these on the podcast before. So my very first time being paid to act was murder mystery dinner theater in St. Louis, Missouri. And it was in the summer after I graduated from college. And I got paid $50 a show. And I did this two-person partially improvised.
这是一种了解你的有趣方式。我们主要要在今天问珍娜这些问题。第一题，你的第一份演艺工作是什么？好吧，我想我以前在播客里聊过这两件事。所以我有生以来第一次因为演戏而获得报酬，是在密苏里州圣路易斯的谋杀之谜晚餐剧场。那是我大学毕业后的那个夏天。我每场演出能拿到 50 美元。我演了一个两人的、部分即兴的
murder mystery dinner theater, you know, in the haunted bed and breakfast restaurant where I saw the ghost and all that. But that was truly the very first time someone paid me to perform. Did you have to play multiple characters or were you just one? I played one character and then the man that I worked with, he played multiple characters. So what was interesting about that was that every time he left the room to change clothes, I had to keep it going. You had to vamp. Yeah, I had to vamp with all. all the people in the room. Yeah, so I played the lady of the house. It was my dinner party that I was
谋杀之谜晚餐剧场，你知道的，是在那个闹鬼的住宿加早餐餐馆里，我还在那儿见到了鬼魂，诸如此类。但那确实是第一次有人付钱让我表演。你必须扮演多个角色，还是只演一个角色？我只演一个角色，然后和我搭档的那位男演员，他扮演多个角色。所以有趣的是，每次他离开房间去换衣服时，我都必须撑住场面。你得即兴发挥。是的，我得和房间里的所有人
throwing. And then he played Jeeves, the butler. He also played the inspector who came to say that a murder had happened. He also played like my dopey brother who maybe was the murderer, but the murderer was always someone in the room because everybody got apart. And so he must have had different accents and things. Different accents, different costumes. He was very tired at the end of the night. I bet. I find it so amazing that, one, your first paid acting job was theater, which is your true love. Yes. And two, it was a dinner party. Yes. And it was in St. Louis. It was in my hometown, which is really cool to me that I didn't even have to leave in order to get paid to do what I love. And then when I came to Los Angeles, my very first acting jobs were all
进行即兴互动。是的，我扮演的女主人。那是我举办的晚宴。然后他扮演管家吉夫斯。他还扮演了前来宣布发生谋杀案的调查员。他还扮演了我那个可能是凶手的蠢弟弟，但凶手其实总是房间里的某个人，因为每个人都有角色。所以他肯定得用不同的口音和装扮。不同的口音，不同的服装。他那天晚上结束时累坏了。我敢打赌。我觉得太神奇了，第一，你的第一份付费演艺工作是戏剧，这是你的真爱。是的。第二，那是一个晚宴派对。是的。而且是在圣路易斯。是在我的家乡，这对我来说真的很酷，我甚至都不用离开家就能靠做自己热爱的事情赚钱。然后当我来到洛杉矶时，我的第一份演艺工作全是
background work. And I told the story of having to ride the Jurassic Park ride for 11 hours to shoot that commercial. And I did background work on the movie Pleasantville with Toby McGuire and Reese Witherspoon. That was like a two-week job. That's an amazing gig. Yeah. And you got to wear like the period kind of piece outfit. I did. That was a crazy one because there's a scene in the movie where, you know, it's the 1950s and people are necking in the cars, you know, the old timing cars. You're like necking. You've gone parking is what they called it. Right, right.
群众演员。我讲过为了拍那个商业广告，不得不连续 11 小时坐侏罗纪公园过山车的经历。我在由托比·马奎尔和瑞茜·威瑟斯彭主演的电影《欢乐谷》里做过群演。那是一份为期两周的工作。那是个超棒的工作。是的。而且你还得穿那种复古时期的服装。是的。那是一次疯狂的经历，因为电影里有一个场景，你知道的，那是 20 世纪 50 年代，人们在车里亲热，你知道的，老派的汽车。就像亲热一样。他们管那叫“去停车场”。对，对。
Making out. Yeah. And so they had to sweep past all of these cars of people making out until they got to, I think, it was Reese Witherspoon in someone. I can't remember now. But you just got paired up with a person in the background, like pool. You were in the car making out? I was in one of the cars.
卿卿我我。是的。所以他们必须从所有这些正在卿卿我我的汽车人群身边扫过，直到他们停在，我想，是瑞茜·威瑟斯彭和某个人身边。我现在记不清了。但你只是在背景里和一个人随机配对，就像拍pool一样。你在车里卿卿我我？我在其中一辆车里。
But were you faky making out? Yeah, faking making out. You just hug, basically. Exactly. But the thing was, everybody wasn't total strangers because we'd all been hanging out in the background area for like so many weeks. But then it was just kind of funny because they just sort of paired us up with someone. They're like, you're in car A, you're in car B. And the little thing just went past. And I was like, oh my house is so weird. If we watch that scene, we'll like see your ponytail or something? No, I got cut out of it. I don't think I'm in the movie at all. Like I was all over the place. I was in the background of the soda shop. I was in one of the cars. I would walk down the street. I'm nowhere to be found. Hey, anyone out there listening that has seen this movie,
但你们是在假装亲热吗？对，假装亲热。基本上就是拥抱。没错。但问题是，大家其实并不完全是陌生人，因为我们在候场区已经一起混了好几个星期了。但后来就觉得挺逗的，因为他们只是随手把你和某个人凑成一对。他们会说：你在 A 车，你在 B 车。然后那个镜头就从旁边滑过去了。当时我在想：哦，我的天，这也太怪了。如果我们看那个镜头，能看到你的马尾辫什么的吗？没有，我被剪掉了。我觉得我根本没出现在电影里。我明明到处都是。我在冰淇淋店的背景里出现过。我在其中一辆车里。我走在街上。结果到处都找不到我。嘿，任何在听节目的朋友，如果你们看过这部电影，
if you think you spotted Jenna, will you do a screen grab and like tag Office Ladies Pod? Incidentally, I had one outfit. So we never changed clothes. So in the soda shop on one day, in the car, walking down the street, I'm always in this yellow outfit with a ponytail. So they gave us one piece of wardrobe,
如果你觉得自己发现了珍娜，能截个图并艾特 @OfficeLadiesPod 吗？顺便说一句，我只有一套戏服。所以我们从来不换衣服。所以在冰淇淋店的那天，在车里，走在街上，我总是穿着这套黄色衣服，扎着马尾辫。所以他们只给了我们一套服装，
and we wore it for two weeks in the background. All right, y'all, look for Jenna and her yellow outfit. fit. Okay. Now, question number two is a little bit of a buffet. There's three that they list, and usually you just answer one. I'm going to make you answer all three. Okay. Okay. Do you speak any other languages? I'll put a fronzie. Oh, okay. May we? Do you play a musical instrument? I do not. You tinkered with a guitar for a hot second. Yeah. You made me walk through an airport carrying it. I carried it. I know, but I had to hold it while you. You went to the bathroom.
我们在背景里穿了两周。好了各位，去找找珍娜和她的黄色衣服吧。好啦。现在，第二题是一个“自助餐”式的题目。列出了三个问题，通常你只需要回答一个。我要让你把三个全回答了。好的。好的。你会说其他语言吗？我会一点法语。哦，好吧。我们可以吗？你会演奏乐器吗？我不会。你曾经为了弹吉他笨手笨脚了一小会儿。是的。你让我背着它走过机场。我背着它。我知道，但是你……你当时去上厕所了，所以我得拿着。
Yes, I thought I was going to play guitar, but then I broke my back on that trip, and I bruised my elbow. And by the time I was healed, I was over the guitar thing. I wish I played the guitar, and I learned piano growing up, but I quit too early. So no, no musical instruments. It's never too late, lady. It's never too late. I feel like it's too late. Okay, it's too late.
是的，我以为我要学弹吉他，但后来我在那次旅行中摔断了背，还把胳膊肘摔淤青了。等我伤好时，我已经对吉他没兴趣了。我希望我会弹吉他，我小时候学过钢琴，但我放弃得太早了。所以，没有，不会任何乐器。女士，活到老学到老，永远都不晚。我觉得已经太晚了。好吧，太晚了。
Forget it. It's too late for me. And do you have a favorite book you've read? this is a tough one. This has got to be such a difficult question for you because I feel like there's at least once a month where you leave me a message where you're like, Angela, this book changed by life. I know, I know. I love every book almost that I read. But I'll say my favorite book that I read last year that keeps coming up for me and has actually impacted my life. You were talking about some of the work that I do for the unhoused community, which I have done for all. long time, but was reinvigorated after reading Demon Copperhead.
算了吧。对我来说太晚了。你有读过最喜欢的书吗？这是一个棘手的问题。这对你来说一定是个很难回答的问题，因为我觉得至少一个月里有那么一次，你会给我留言说：安吉拉，这本书改变了我的人生。我知道，我知道。几乎我读过的每一本书我都喜欢。但我要说的是，我去年读过的、不断在我脑海中浮现并真正对我的生活产生影响的最喜欢的书。你刚才提到我为无家可归者社区做的一些工作，我做这件事已经很久了，但在读完《恶魔铜斑蛇》之后，我重新燃起了热情。
Yeah. I absolutely loved that book. And within that book, it's, you know, about the struggles of this young man who ends up losing both of his parents and he's put into foster care and he's hungry a lot. And along the way in his life, it got emotional, even just thinking about it, like he's such a real person to me, along the way, there are just every once in a while, someone's kind to him and just creates a human moment with him. That's the thing you shared with me is like giving someone a moment of humanity.
是的。我绝对太喜欢那本书了。在这本书里，你知道的，讲述了这个年轻人的挣扎，他最终失去了双亲，被送进了寄养家庭，经常挨饿。在他的人生旅程中——甚至一想到这，我都觉得情绪涌动，他对我来说就像一个真实存在的人——一路上，每隔一段时间，就会有人对展现出善意，与他产生真正的人性连接。这就是你跟我分享的理念，就是“给予某人一份人性的关怀”。
Yeah. And so that became sort of a goal of mine is just there's a lot of unhoused people in Los Angeles. And just the idea that maybe for a brief moment, if they encounter me, I just create that moment of kindness and offer help and support, along with working with some organizations that help with housing and outreach and clothing and things like that. But for me, it's a very personal one-on-one thing. And it's really due to that book of just the moments when in the book, someone would offer him food. And I would just be so happy that someone was kind to him. Yeah. And I felt it so deeply. I thought, oh, my God.
是的。所以这成了我的一个目标，洛杉矶有很多无家可归的人。只要想到也许在短暂的瞬间，当他们遇到我时，我能创造那种善良的时刻，并提供帮助和支持，同时与一些致力于住房、外展服务、衣物等方面的组织合作。但对我来说，这是一件非常个人化的一对一的事情。这确实是因为那书里描绘的那些时刻：书中有人给他提供食物。我会因为有人对他好而感到由衷的高兴。是的。我对此感同身受。我想，哦，天哪。
God, I just, I want to be that for somebody if I can. Right. So that book just is a great book. It's a great story. And if I'm making it sound heavy, one of the amazing things about the narrator of the book, who is the boy, is he's funny and he is hopeful. And so it's just a really powerful book and entertaining and easy to read. So I loved it.
上帝啊，我只是——如果可以的话，我也想成为那样的人。所以那真的是一本很棒的书。这是一个很棒的故事。如果我把它说得很沉重的话，这本书的叙述者——也就是那个男孩——最棒的一点在于，他是幽默的，他是充满希望的。所以这真的是一本很有力量、充满娱乐性且易读的书。我太喜欢了。
And now I am reading another of her books. Barbara Kings Oliver? Yes. Yeah. I am reading the point. Poisonwood Bible, which is also just great so far. I mean, I'm 40 pages in, but very excited. Great. Well, I think that's a fantastic recommendation you guys out there listening. We all need to read it. Yeah, it's great. All right. One of my favorite questions whenever we have a guest,
现在我正在读她的另一本书。芭芭拉·金索沃的？是的。是的。我在读《毒木圣经》（The Poisonwood Bible），目前为止也觉得非常棒。我是说，我才读了 40 页，但非常兴奋。太棒了。好吧，我觉得这是一个极好的推荐，在听节目的各位，我们都应该去读一读。是的，真的很棒。好啦。每当有嘉宾来时，我最喜欢的问题之一就是，
because I'm just so curious about where people love to go in the world, what's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved. All right, I'm going to divide this into domestically and internationally. Oh, great. Domestically, Oklahoma City, and Chicago. Last year, I got to go to both of those cities for different projects. And you got to really live in both of those cities. Yes. You had an Airbnb and you lived there and you had your market and you met people and your cafes. Yes. I absolutely fell in love with Oklahoma City and the people of Oklahoma city, their crazy wackadoodle weather where it's like an ice storm and then 36 hours later, it's 78 degrees. I was like, what's happening here? And there's like tornado sirens going off.
因为我太好奇大家喜欢去世界的哪个角落了，你有没有去过哪个地方是你绝对深爱的？好吧，我要把它分为国内和国外。哦，太棒了。在国内，是俄克拉何马城和芝加哥。去年，我因为不同的项目去了这两座城市。而且你真的在两座城市都生活过。是的。你租了 Airbnb，你在那里生活，有你固定的集市，你结识了当地人，还有你的咖啡馆。是的。我彻底爱上了俄克拉何马城以及那里的人民，他们那疯狂古怪的天气：一会儿是冰暴，然后 36 小时后又是 78 度。我当时想：这到底是怎么回事？还有龙卷风警报在拉响。
And also the people locally, they're like, yep, we love it. And I'm like, I get it. I don't know. There's something about it. You're like, and maybe it's because we live in the perpetual sunshine of Los Angeles. But this idea that the weather could be literally. anything tomorrow was very cool and exciting and weird. Exactly. And, you know, my family in North Texas is kind of in that same corridor that Oklahoma City is in. And it brings community together because you're like, yes, a bunch trees are coming down because of this wind. Okay, everybody lets it. And then, you know, all of a sudden there's a heat wave and then it's like pray for rain. And it's like, you know, you just never know. Yes. But also the food. The food was so good.
而且当地人却觉得：耶，我们可太喜欢了。我就想：我懂了。不知道为什么，就是有那么一种感觉。你会想，也许是因为我们生活在洛杉矶永恒的阳光中。但这种明天的天气可能字面意义上是任何情况的想法，真是太酷、太刺激、太诡异了。没错。而且，你知道的，我在北德克萨斯的家人也差不多在俄克拉何马城所在的那个走廊地带。这把社区凝聚在了一起，因为你会想：没错，因为这风，一堆树要倒了。好吧，大家都随遇而安吧。然后，你知道的，突然来了一场热浪，接着大家又开始“祈求下雨”。这就好像，你知道的，你永远猜不到。是的。还有食物。那里的食物太好吃了。
everywhere I went to eat was so good. There was like this little taco place near our Airbnb that, I mean, we ordered from constantly. And this ramen place that was so good. But all the restaurants, everywhere we ate was great. Lee had to go back recently, and I was so jealous because I wanted to go with him. He had to do a screening of the movie for the crew. New Year's Rev. New Year's Rev. It's coming out this year, although I think the name is changing. Oh, yeah? Yeah. Once it's final, we can talk about it. But yeah, he did a screening for the crew. And I was like, oh, my God, are you going to eat here? Are you going to? He was only there for two days. I was like, where are you going to eat? Because the food was so good. And then, of course, I have gone on and on about Chicago. I just fell in love with that city as well.
我去的每一家餐馆都那么好吃。我们 Airbnb 附近有一家小墨西哥卷饼店，我的天，我们天天点外卖。还有那家拉面店，太好吃了。但所有的餐馆，我们吃过的地方都很棒。李最近不得不回去了一次，我当时嫉妒得要命，因为我也想跟他一起去。他得为剧组放映这部电影。新年夜。新年夜。今年要上映，虽然我觉得名字可能会改。哦，是吗？是的。等最终敲定后，我们可以聊聊。但总之，他为剧组办了一场放映会。我当时想：哦，天哪，你会在那儿吃东西吗？你会去……他只呆了两天。我问：你打算去哪儿吃？因为那里的食物太美味了。然后，当然了，我对芝加哥赞不绝口。我也彻底爱上了那座城市。
Love Chicago. So those are my domestic loves. And then internationally, I loved Copenhagen. Tell me about Copenhagen. I've never been. It is such a charming city. We went as a family. and in the middle of the city, they have an amusement park called Tivoli Gardens, which, Angela, you would love because it's also like a botanical gardens. And you can buy a ticket just to walk around or you can buy a ticket that includes rides. So I bought the walk around ticket. Lee and the kids bought the one for rides. They've got this old roller coaster that is like so old that there's a man that sits in the back and does a break. for when you go around turns.
超爱芝加哥。所以这些是我的国内挚爱。而在国际上，我最爱哥本哈根。跟我讲讲哥本哈根吧。我从来没去过。那是一个非常有魅力的城市。我们全家一起去的。在市中心，他们有一个叫蒂沃利花园的游乐园，安吉拉，你一定会喜欢，因为它同时也是一个植物园。你可以买一张只进去散步的门票，也可以买一张包含游乐设施的通票。所以我买了散步票。李和孩子们买了游乐设施票。他们有一个老式过山车，古老到后面要坐一个工作人员，在过弯道时负责踩刹车。
Oh, my gosh. Isn't that crazy? He's paying attention that day. Oh, my gosh. But there's also like a loop-de-loop, like a more modern roller coaster. It's great. I guess it's supposedly the amusement park that Disneyland was originally based on, and I get it. But it's just super cute.
哦，天哪。是不是很疯狂？他那天必须得高度集中注意力。哦，天哪。但也有那种回旋轨道，更现代一点的过山车。太棒了。我听说据说这是迪士尼乐园最初仿照建造的游乐园，我能理解。反正就是超级可爱。
But we also went to a soccer game there, a football, excuse me. Yeah, a football game. Mm-hmm, which was really cool. And we also rented like a little electric boat and brought a picnic dinner out on the canals and we like putted around the canals. But it was great. It's a great walking city. It was just cool. And again, had great food. If you have good food, I'm going to come to your city. Chita's going to visit. Exactly. So tell her where to eat. She'll be there. Okay. Well, I love those answers. And number four is, what do you like to do on the weekends?
我们在那里还看了一场足球比赛，足球，不好意思。是的，一场足球比赛。嗯哼，真的非常酷。我们还租了一艘小电动船，带上野餐晚餐去运河上，我们在运河里优哉游哉地划船。真的很棒。这是一个非常适合步行游览的城市。总之太酷了。而且再次强调，那里的食物很好吃。只要有好吃的，我就会去你们的城市。奇塔就要去拜访。没错。所以告诉她去哪儿吃。她绝对会去。好的。好吧，我太喜欢这些答案了。第四题是，你周末喜欢做什么？
Well, I run a small taxi service for two very demanding clients every weekend. Your clients are, how old? They are 14 and 11. Okay. They have a lot of extracurriculars. So truly, when I say I run a car service, you know, I do the scheduling, which driver, we've got two drivers, me and Lee. Right. So you have two kids with very different interests.
好吧，我每个周末都要为两位要求极高的客户经营一家小型出租车服务公司。你的客户多大了？他们一个 14 岁，一个 11 岁。好吧。他们有很多课外活动。所以真的，当我说是开汽车服务时，你知道的，我负责排班，哪个司机——我们有两个司机，我和李。对。所以你有两个兴趣截然不同的孩子。
Yes. And you're driving them all over town. It's all I do all weekend. Half the time on the weekend, you and I trade messages. You're like, well, I'm back in the car. Yeah. All over the city. That's basically my weekend.
是的。你要开车把他们送到镇上的各个地方。我整个周末都在干这个。周末有一半时间，你和我都在发信息。你会说：嗯，我又在车上了。是的。跑遍全城。这就是我的周末。
Every weekend is just shuttling kids to things. But. I'm sorry. I think the question is what do you like to do on the weekends? Not what you actually do on the weekend. Okay. You're right. Okay.
每个周末就是把孩子们送到各个地方。但是。抱歉。我觉得问题是你周末喜欢做什么，而不是你周末实际上在做什么。好吧。你说得对。好吧。
Well, I have been able to carve out sometimes both on Saturday and Sunday, but at least one or the other. I sleep in, which I really like. By sleep in, I mean like 8 a.m. Maybe 8.30, if I'm lucky, that's kind of cool. And then I get my cup of coffee and I go upstairs to my reading nook and I read my book for a long time. If I get to read during the week, maybe it's only for 15 minutes. But on a weekend, I create the space where I get to just sink into my cozy chair and my little nook at the top of my stairs. with my fabulous chairs and my wallpaper.
好吧，我确实能够挤出一些时间，有时在周六和周日，但至少在其中一天，我可以睡个懒觉，我真的很喜欢。所谓睡到自然醒，就是大概早上 8 点。也许 8 点半，如果我运气好的话，那感觉挺爽的。然后我喝着咖啡，上楼去我的阅读角，读好长时间的书。如果我在工作日读书，可能只有 15 分钟。但在周末，我会腾出空间，舒舒服服地陷进我楼梯顶部的舒适椅子和那个小小的阅读角落里。配上我那些漂亮的椅子和壁纸。
Your wallpaper. This nook, okay, so you've had that house a long time, but y'all, this nook was like that little kind of square off the top of your stairs. It's like the landing. It's next to the linen cabinet. Yeah, and for years you're like, wait, I don't know what to do with this space. I don't know, I don't know what it is. It's not big enough like to really put too much in it.
你的壁纸。这个角落，好吧，你那房子买了好久了，但是各位，这个角落就像是你楼梯顶上那个稍微隔出来的小空间。有点像平台。就在亚麻布柜旁边。是的，多年来你一直说：等等，我不知道该拿这个空间怎么办。我不知道，我不知道这是个啥。它不够大，放不下太多东西。
And then it just kind of became a catch-all a little bit. And then you made it this cozy nook. And lady, it's brought you so much joy. It's where I read now. And I love it. It's where I did all my prep for the play. I really like it. It's my quiet spot.
然后它不知怎么就成了个杂物堆放处。再然后你把它打造成了这个温馨的角落。女士，它给你带来了无尽的欢乐。我现在就在那儿读书。我太喜欢了。我为那部戏剧做所有的排练都是在那里进行的。我真的很喜欢。那是我的安静角落。
So, yeah, that's what I like to do. And I make sure that my weekend, one of the days, sometimes both, includes that. And I'll sit there from like 8.30 to 10 o'clock. Oh, wow. That's amazing. And then I have to start. They have to go to work. Yeah.
所以，是的，这就是我喜欢做的事。我确保我的周末里有一天——有时两天——能包含这个时间。我会在那儿从大约 8 点半坐到 10 点。哦，哇。太棒了。然后我就得开工了。他们得去工作了。是的。
You have to go drive your clients around town. Exactly. All right. Last call sheet question. What is your favorite midnight snack? Well, I think it's cereal. If I'm going to have a snack, and I'm interpreting midnight snack as just like 9 p.m. Yeah, exactly.
你得去开车送你的客户们满城跑了。没错。最后一个通告单问题。你最喜欢的深夜零食是什么？好吧，我觉得是麦片。如果我要吃点零食的话——而且我把深夜零食理解为大概晚上 9 点左右。是的，没错。
Like, well, my midnight. Yeah, we're not up that late anymore. Pre-bedtime snack. If I'm going to get hungry and want to eat something, it's going to be cereal. And currently, I'm into frosted mini-weets. Oh, really? I know. It used to be lucky charms, but now frosted mini-weets.
就像，好吧，对我的深夜来说。是的，我们现在没那么晚睡了。睡前小吃。如果我饿了想吃点东西，那肯定就是麦片。目前，我迷上了霜糖迷你威他麦（frosted mini-wheats）。哦，真的吗？我知道。以前是幸运符麦片（Lucky Charms），但现在是霜糖迷你威他麦。
Your cereal always has a little punch of sugar in it. It does. it packs a punch. But when I was younger and I really did eat things at midnight, my two favorites were like a big tub of frozen yogurt or, you know, Ben and Jerry's ice cream. Or for a very long time, I would watch TV and eat easy cheese on top of wheat thins. That's hilarious. Well, lady, all of those answers are so authentically you. and you're really fun to hang out with.
你的麦片总是带有一点糖分冲击。确实。很有冲击力。但当我更年轻、真的在半夜吃东西的时候，我的最爱是一大桶冷冻酸奶，或者，你知道的，本杰瑞冰淇淋。或者很长一段时间里，我一边看电视一边吃涂着易挤芝士（easy cheese）的小麦饼干（wheat thins）。太搞笑了。好吧，女士，所有这些答案都太有你的个人风格了。而且和你在一起玩真的很有趣。
Hey, thanks. Yeah, you're a good hang, as they say. Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, I think we should have an Around the Town and then end with an office question of the week. Let's do it. Right, Sam, we're back. How about some Around the Town action?
嘿，谢谢。是的，正如他们所说，你是个很棒的玩伴。我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来之后，我觉得我们应该进行一个“走遍小镇”环节，然后以每周办公室问题收尾。就这么办。好啦，山姆，我们回来了。“走遍小镇”活动怎么样？
Around the Town. Our first message comes from Julia H in Connecticut, who said Julia and Sarah, who have been friends since 2016 when they joined the University of Connecticut marching band as clarinet players, celebrated their 28th birthdays over the weekend. They hosted a, quote, Bob party, where their friends, who are also clarinet players, came dressed as characters who would have Bob haircuts. The party also included pizza and ice cream cake for dessert.
走遍小镇。我们的第一条留言来自康涅狄格州的茱莉亚·H，她说茱莉亚和莎拉自从 2016 年加入康涅狄格大学行进乐队担任单簧管手以来一直是好朋友，她们周末庆祝了 28 岁生日。她们举办了一个“波波头派对”（Bob party），她们的朋友们——同样是单簧管手——都打扮成留着波波头发型的角色前来参加。派对上还准备了披萨和冰淇淋蛋糕作为甜点。
That is hilarious. I have never heard of a Bob party. Julia, I wish you would have told us who all the bob haircut people were. Oh my gosh, I wish we had a picture. Like, my first thing I think of is that scene in Fleabag. Yes, yes. The sister gets the haircut and she's like, I look like a pencil. I thought, and I don't know if this is a bob, but I did think of Merrill Streep's character from the Devil Wears Prada.
太搞笑了。我从来没听说过波波头派对。茱莉亚，我真希望你们能告诉我们所有那些留着波波头的人都是谁。哦，天哪，我真希望能看到照片。比如，我脑子里首先想到的是《伦敦生活》里的那个场景。是的，是的。妹妹剪了头发，然后她说：我看起来像支铅笔。我想，我不知道这算不算波波头，但我确实想到了梅丽尔·斯特里普在《穿普拉达的女王》里的角色。
Oh. Is that kind of a bob? That's a sassy bob. Maybe. Or isn't the famous Bob right now your friend? Leslie Bibb, her character in... White Lotus. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
哦。那算是一种时髦的波波头吗？也许吧。或者现在最著名的波波头不就是你的朋友吗？莱斯利·比布，她在……《白莲花度假村》里的角色。对。是的。没错。
Okay. Our next around the town is from Ashley B. in Kent, Ohio. Ashley says, hi, Jenna and Angela. The Akron Zoo in Akron, Ohio, through a 25th birthday party for their tawny frogmouth owl. His name is Buzz, and he is one of their animal ambassadors, so he does not have a public exhibit. But you can see the decor, which I think you'll very much enjoy on their social media. hopefully this link will work. Oh my gosh. It's amazing.
好的。我们的下一个“走遍小镇”来自俄亥俄州肯特的阿什利·B。阿什利说：嗨，珍娜和安吉拉。俄亥俄州阿克伦市的阿克伦动物园为他们的黄颊鹰鸮（tawny frogmouth owl）举办了 25 岁生日派对。它的名字叫巴斯（Buzz），它是他们的动物形象大使之一，所以它没有公开展示的展馆。但你可以在他们的社交媒体上看到装饰，我想你们会非常喜欢的。希望这个链接能打开。哦，天哪。太棒了。
It is an owl sitting on his perch and behind him is a banner that says it is your birthday. And then there's all the sad balloons. Partially like deflated balloons. That is hilarious. Yes. I will share that in stories. Oh my gosh. Thank you for sending that, Ashley.
这是一只坐在栖木上的猫头鹰，它身后挂着一条横幅，上面写着生日快乐。然后还有所有那些悲伤的气球。有点像瘪了的气球。太搞笑了。是的。我会把它分享到快拍里。哦天哪。谢谢你发给我，阿什莉。
I loved that. And now Alicia W. from Norfolk, Nebraska said, At the parking lot of our local Chipotle, there is one of those little strips of grass and landscaping, and instead of going around this, people would drive straight through the grass. They would just drive right over the median kind of thing.
我很喜欢那个。现在来自内布拉斯加州诺福克的艾丽西亚·W说，在我们当地奇波雷餐厅的停车场里，有一小片草坪和绿化带，人们不绕过它，而是直接把车开过草坪。他们基本上就是直接从隔离带上开过去。
Yes. Yeah. So, to combat this, the owners decided to place a large boulder amongst the landscaping. Unfortunately, we rural Nebraskaans are such creatures of habit that not one, but several cars have actually driven their same route through the landscaping and gotten their vehicle stuck on the rock. It was such a sensation that some people actually created a Facebook group called
是的。是的。所以，为了制止这种行为，业主决定在绿化带中间放一块大圆石。不幸的是，我们这些乡村内布拉斯加人习惯成自然，不仅有一辆，而且有好几辆车真的沿着他们习惯的路线穿过绿化带，把车卡在了石头上。这甚至成了一种轰动，以至于有些人还建立了一个名为
the Rock of Norfolk and named the Rock Ron for Rock of Norfolk. Ron's group has 5.8,000 members, which is 23% of our town's population, and I counted pictures of five or six different vehicles that got stuck on him. After the drama, they finally added a protective circle of poles around Ron, but you can still go visit him. And he has officially been added to Google Maps as a tourist attraction. Well, Alicia, we love this story so much. I actually found a news station that covered it. They're local in Nebraska.
诺福克之石的脸书群组，并给这块石头起名叫罗恩，代表诺福克之石（Rock of Norfolk）。罗恩的群组有5800名成员，占我们镇人口的23%，我数了数，上面有五六辆不同车辆卡在它上面的照片。闹剧过后，他们终于在罗恩周围加了一圈保护柱，但你仍然可以去参观它。它甚至已经被正式添加到谷歌地图上，成了一个旅游景点。好吧，艾丽西亚，我们太喜欢这个故事了。我甚至找到了一家报道它的新闻台。他们是内布拉斯加当地的。
And it's really funny. They show all the pictures of the vehicle. that have been stuck on this rock. And the rock is big. Yeah. There's no way you're going to drive right at it and think I'm going to go over that. It's clearly muscle memory. Yeah.
而且真的很好笑。他们展示了所有被卡在这块石头上的车辆的照片。而且这块石头很大。是的。你绝不可能径直开过去还以为自己能开过去。这绝对是肌肉记忆。是的。
People are not paying attention. The rock is there. It's big. Anyway, I'm going to put the news broadcast in our stories. Thank you guys all so much for writing in. I love around the towns. All right. Well, now it's time for our office question of the week.
人们根本没注意。石头就在那里。而且很大。总之，我把新闻广播放到我们的快拍里。非常感谢大家写信来。我很喜欢走访小镇这个环节。好了，现在是我们的每周办公室问答时间。
It comes from Phil H. in Spring, Texas, which is right outside of Houston. Phil says the series showed the wedding of Pam and Jim and Dwight and Angela. Was there a reason why the wedding of Michael and Holly was not in an episode of The Office? There is. And it's probably a pretty boring reason. Right. Because, man, that would have made a great episode. I would have loved to see their wedding.
这个问题来自德克萨斯州斯普林的菲尔·H，就在休斯顿郊外。菲尔说，剧集展现了潘和吉姆以及德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼。为什么迈克尔和霍莉的婚礼没有出现在《办公室》的一集里呢？原因其实是有的。而且可能是一个挺无聊的原因。对啊，因为，天哪，那一定会是很棒的一集。我本很想看他们的婚礼。
Because, you know, Michael's going to be Bridezilla. You think? Yes. And I think Holly's just going to let him have his moment. But I think Michael's going to have really strong feelings about his. his wedding day. Do you think they would have traded vows like in a Yoda voice? Oh, I think they would have for sure written their own vows, which I would have just loved to hear. Mindy, Mindy Kaling, can we call her and be like, will you write these right now so we can read them on the podcast? Yeah, I think at some point
因为，你知道的，迈克尔肯定会变成个新娘zilla。你觉得吗？是的。而且我觉得霍莉只会让他享受他的高光时刻。但我认为迈克尔对他的婚礼当天会有非常强烈的感受。你觉得他们会用尤达的语气宣读誓言吗？哦，我觉得他们肯定会自己写誓言，我真的很想听听。明迪，明迪·卡林，我们能给她打电话说，你现在能把这些写下来好让我们在播客里读出来吗？是的，我觉得在某个时刻
in the wedding vows, there would have been some type of like accents, character impersonations, things like that. I feel like there would have been maybe some like Princess Bride references. Oh, marriage. Marriage. Wings us together. Yeah. Yeah.
在婚礼誓言中，肯定会出现某种口音、角色模仿之类的东西。我觉得可能还会有一些《公主新娘》的梗。哦，婚姻。婚姻。将我们紧紧相连。对。对。
The holy spigot. Yeah. For sure. I don't know. There just would have been a lot of voices. There are you, I will. Yeah, there you go. But it would have been really joyous.
神圣的龙头。对。肯定的。我不知道。总之会有很多声音。有你，我愿意。对，就是这样。但那一定非常欢乐。
We'll tell you why it didn't happen. It was because, first of all, Steve Correll was no longer under contract with the show, you know. Michael Marries Holly somewhere in season eight or nine. When he shows up for the finale, you know, it's years later. So that wedding happened off camera. But both Amy and Steve had already left the show and were doing other things. And so we just didn't get to see their wedding.
我们来告诉你为什么没有发生。首先，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔当时已经不再与该剧有合约在身了，你知道的。迈克尔在第八季或第九季的某个时候娶了霍莉。当他出现在大结局时，你知道的，已经是多年以后了。所以那场婚礼是在镜头外发生的。但艾米和史蒂夫当时都已经离开剧组去忙别的事情了。所以我们只是没能看到他们的婚礼。
But, man, I so wish that we could have. Yeah. I mean, I think he would have had to make Dwight his best man. You think? Yeah. He wouldn't have tried to make, like, Ryan, his best man or Danny Cordray or one of the last. He would have tried. And, but I think it would have ended up being Dwight.
但是，天哪，我多希望我们能看到啊。对。我是说，我觉得他肯定会让德怀特当他的伴郎。你觉得呢？对。他不会试图让，比如，瑞安当他的伴郎，或者丹尼·科德雷，或者其他人。他肯定试过。但我觉得最后还是会落到德怀特头上。
I do. You do? Yeah, because he would have taken care of Michael and made sure it was all of Michael's favorite things. But there would have been at least one moment where he went too big. And Michael would have been like, damn it, Dwight. I think there might have been a full choir that sings. Mm-hmm. I could see that.
我也是。是吗？对，因为他会照顾好迈克尔，确保这一切都是迈克尔最喜欢的东西。但肯定会有至少一个时刻，他做得太过头了。然后迈克尔会说，该死，德怀特。我觉得可能还有一个现场演唱的完整唱诗班。嗯哼。我能想象到。
Right. Yeah. Yeah. They would have done the cut the cake thing, and they're both such dorks, the cake theme. What would the cake have been? Oh, that's a good question. Just all the little touches would have been so fun. Yeah, it's too bad.
对。对。对。他们会做切蛋糕的环节，而且他们两个都是大笨蛋，切蛋糕环节。那蛋糕会是什么样的呢？哦，这是个好问题。所有的小细节都会非常有趣。对，太遗憾了。
Oh, you know what I think? Last thing. Because now I'm just so excited, just kind of envisioning the Michael and Holly wedding. I think for sure the two of them would have spent weeks working on a choreographed first dance. Yes. That they would have performed for everyone. Yes. But I also think Michael would have insisted that everybody lift him up on a chair, even though it was not a Jewish wedding.
哦，你知道我觉得什么吗？最后一点。因为现在我太兴奋了，脑子里一直在构想迈克尔和霍莉的婚礼。我觉得他们俩肯定花了好几个星期来排练一支编排好的第一支舞。是的。他们会为所有人表演。是的。但我也觉得迈克尔会坚持让所有人都把他抬在椅子上，尽管这不是一场犹太婚礼。
Yeah, he would have wanted that tradition. The moment. Yes, because he had seen it in a movie or something. Right. Or they would have, like, entered their reception in like a ye oldie carriage or something. I was at a wedding one time where the bride and groom entered in a horse-drawn carriage. They entered the indoors? It was like a Cinderella carriage.
对，他会想要那个传统。那个时刻。是的，因为他在电影里看到过类似的东西。没错。或者他们会像，坐着一辆复古马车什么的进入他们的招待会。我曾经去过一个婚礼，新郎新娘是坐着马车进场的。他们进入室内了？那就像是一辆灰姑娘的马车。
They entered a ballroom. With actual horses. One horse pulling like a little Cinderella round rod iron carriage that they sat in. Do I know these people? No. No. This was a huge Dallas, Texas wedding. Wow.
他们进入了一个宴会厅。还有真马。一匹马拉着一辆灰姑娘坐的那种小巧的圆形锻铁马车。我认识这些人吗？不。不。这是一场德克萨斯州达拉斯的豪华婚礼。哇。
Yeah. And I literally like the big doors open and then you're like, clip, clop, clop, cleop. I was like, what is happening? Am I an old lady? Because when I hear that I think, oh, what a waste of money. No, you should just, you know what, use that for some good bed linens. Well, you know what, double up on all your sheets. That's a better way to spend your money on it. Get the good towels. Yeah, exactly. That carriage. I'm like, you'll use the towels forever. Yeah. Also, you know, the number of mishaps that can happen getting in and out of that carriage in your dress with your fancy shoes. Yeah. Go get the towels. We're practical ladies. We are.
对。我真的就像听到大门打开，然后就是，哒哒哒，哒哒哒。当时我就想，发生什么事了？我是个老太太吗？因为当我听到这个的时候，我会想，哦，真是浪费钱。不，你应该，你知道吗，把这钱用来买点好的床单。好吧，你知道吗，把所有的床单都买双份。这才是花钱的更好方式。买好的毛巾。对，完全正确。那辆马车。我就觉得，毛巾你一辈子都能用。对。还有，你知道，穿着华丽的礼服和鞋子上下那辆马车可能会出多少意外。对。去买毛巾吧。我们是很务实的女士。我们确实是。
But also, if you want a carriage at your wedding, you do you. Yes, that's right. I don't judge. I just can't relate. It's different. Stitch that on a pillow. I don't judge. I just can't relate.
但话说回来，如果你婚礼上想要一辆马车，你开心就好。是的，没错。我不予评判。我只是无法感同身受。这就是不同之处。把它绣在枕头上。我不予评判。我只是无法感同身受。
It's actually a really great pillow. Well, you guys, this has been really great. Thank you. I feel so celebrated. Angela, when your birthday comes up, we're going to have to do the same thing. You have to answer the call sheet questions now. It was your idea. started it. Okay. Now you have to do it. Oh, great. All right. Sam, Matt, one of your birthdays.
这其实是一个非常棒的枕头。好了，各位，这期节目真的很棒。谢谢你们。我觉得自己备受庆祝。安吉拉，等你的生日到了，我们也得这么来一次。你现在得回答通告单上的问题了。这是你的主意。你挑起的头。好吧。现在你得照做了。哦，太棒了。好吧。萨姆，马特，你们谁的生日。
I'm not the only one doing this. And maybe we'll come up with some tribute to you that's like, I'm thinking maybe tennis related. Do we have to share our favorite tennis moment from history? Mine was a surprise to you. Okay. Our shared moment was a surprise. You have to surprise me. Okay. I don't want to know. Okay. But I get to pick my own theme, lady. You don't get to pick my birthday thing. Okay, you pick your theme and then that will point us in a direction. I like it. Okay. Well, thank you, everybody. This was really fun. All right. We'll see you guys next week. We hope you had a great one. Thanks for writing in. We appreciate y'all so much. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. And our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies, we'll be. was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. Lady, have you ever invested in something that seemed really amazing at first,
可不光是我一个人在经历这个。也许我们会为你准备某种致敬环节，比如，我在想要不要和网球有关。我们得分享我们历史中喜欢的网球时刻吗？我的对你来说是个惊喜。好吧。我们共同的时刻是个惊喜。你得给我个惊喜。好吧。我不想提前知道。好吧，那你可以选择你自己的主题，女士。你不能选我的生日主题。好吧，你选你的主题，然后这会给我们指明一个方向。我喜欢。好吧。谢谢大家。这真的很有趣。好啦。我们下周见。希望你们过得愉快。谢谢你们来信。我们非常感激大家。下周见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是奥德赛（Audyssey）出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertry》。女士，你有没有投资过一开始看起来非常棒，
but then did not live up to the hype? I once got this kind of fancy jacket that looked amazing in the store, but then I wore it out once, and I realized it was not comfortable, and now it just lives in my closet collecting dust. LinkedIn has a word for that, bull spin, Bullspend is when you optimize for numbers that look great, impressions, reach, reactions, but then those numbers don't actually drive revenue. Invest in what actually looks good to your CFO.
但后来却名不符其实的东西？我曾经买过一件那种很时髦的夹克，在店里看起来棒极了，但我穿出去过一次，然后我意识到它一点也不舒服，现在它只能待在我的衣橱里积灰。领英（LinkedIn）对这种现象有一个词，叫虚荣指标（bullspin），虚荣指标是指你为了那些看起来很棒的数据而进行优化，曝光量、触达量、互动量，但这些数据实际上并不能带来营收。去投资那些对你的首席财务官来说真正好看的东西。
LinkedIn ads generate the highest ROAS, 121% of all major ad networks. You can reach the right buyers by targeting company, industry, job title, and more. So cut the bullspend. Advertise on LinkedIn, the network that works for you. Spend $250 on your first campaign on LinkedIn ads and get a $250 credit for the next one. Just go to LinkedIn.com slash office. That's LinkedIn.com slash office.
领英广告产生的广告投资回报率（ROAS）最高，占所有主要广告网络总额的121%。你可以通过按公司、行业、职位等进行定向来触达正确的买家。所以，别再关注虚荣指标了。在领英上投放广告吧，这是一个真正为你带来成效的网络。在领英广告上为你的首次投放花费250美元，即可获得下次投放的250美元额度。只需访问 LinkedIn.com/office。即 LinkedIn.com/office。
Terms and conditions apply. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
条款和条件适用。本集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。